we notice a trend of you following a  certain Twitter account and commenting  on their posts  you kind of seem interested in a lot of  food  yeah  this is a cheeseburger chocolate chip  cookie and it doesn't look that bad  exactly right this is a an abomination  of God yeah you would eat it here's what  we've done we prepared all this food  [Applause]  wait I am so excited so this is two  chocolate chip cookies and a  cheeseburger in the middle cheers for  real  oh it's not it no that's not it  so this is called the Oreo Burger Bucky  I love it oh that's [ __ ] gross  looking  the Oreo is very overpowering I'm gonna  do another one  you like it  do you like it better though than just a  big man yeah wow